Christianity is revealing to you the
pattern of reality of how it is that
complexity Works how it is that any type
of unity and multiplicity cohere but
that also means that you you know it is
calling you to actually participate in
that in a real
[Music]
way this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to
the symbolic
[Applause]
World hello everyone as we are coming
closer to theophany and in the western
tradition Epiphany which in the Orthodox
Church is mostly surrounding the baptism
of Christ I thought we could look at one
verse in the Bible which talks about the
baptism of Christ CHR I chosen a virgin
in the gospel of St Matthew could have
chosen another virgin in another gospel
uh to see just how much it packs in
terms of understanding so many things
related to Christianity whether it is
this idea of the new birth or being born
again the idea of the new creation you
know what it is that Christ represent in
the uh in the story all the meaning of
theophany and the baptism of Christ is
of course contain in the icon of the
baptism of Christ but what I thought is
we'll look at the text first and then
maybe we'll come back to the icon a
little bit later to see what it is that
the icon contains in terms of this
mystery now we'll go into the gospel of
Matthew chapter 3 where it says that as
soon as Jesus was baptized he went up
out of the water at that moment heaven
was opened and he saw the Spirit spirit
of God descending like a dove and a
lighting on him and a voice from Heaven
said this is my son whom I love with him
I am well pleased now of course this is
seen in the Orthodox tradition and in
Christianity in general as the
revelation of the Trinity which is that
we hear the the voice of God the father
of God above who says this is my son and
then we see the spirit descending like a
dove on on Christ that comes out of the
water and so it's seen as a revelation
of the Trinity but there's also
something else really going on here
which is that when Christ comes out of
the water and the spirit of God comes
down on him like a dove what we're
seeing is a reference to two stories in
the Old Testament at the same time first
is the very beginning of Genesis where
it says that the spirit of God hovered
above the waters so at the beginning of
Genesis you have this before creation
even starts you have this image of of
these chaotic Waters underneath and of
the spirit of God above the waters right
it's a it's a basic Cosmic image of
Heaven above right because there's no
difference between Heaven uh spirit and
air all of these things are related so
when it says spirit in the old in the
Old Testament or in the New Testament
for that matter it is the same as wind
or you know what's above this this
invisible thing that moves above that
you can't see moving but you see its
effects and so this is what is above and
then below are the waters so it's
referring to that but then it's also
referring to the end of the flood of
course because at the end of the flood
Noah sends out a dove and then that Dove
finds a branch by which it is able to
know that the flood has Abad and that
the new world has begun and so what is
all going on here so of course what
we're seeing is a new beginning we're
seeing a new creation in this particular
instance Christ appears as the tree the
branch that the branch that the bird
comes and finds and when we hear the
word branch and when we hear the word
tree we always have to remember that a
tree is the is the pattern of reality
itself that it is the fractal pattern of
reality of unity splitting into
multiplicity and that mult that new
multip unity and now splitting again
into multiplicities right the the
structure of a tree which is which is
that exactly one and many joining
together in a in a in a pattern of
hierarchy that is how reality lays
itself out that is the structure of the
world that is what connects Heaven and
Earth together is this embodied
structure that manifests itself right
and so you could say that the tree is
the connection between Heaven and Earth
it is the invisible principles of
reality manifesting themselves in an
embodied form so that you can see the
pattern of the heavens the pattern of
reality in on the earth connected to the
Earth so it's like a a bridge between
the two between the whole completely
invisible patterns and the you know the
chaotic primordial Earth and so in this
context now Christ appears as this new
connection between Heaven and Earth as a
connection between Heaven and Earth and
so what like I said was joined together
is the first chapter of Genesis that is
the actual creation of the word of the
world and now the the second world which
is after the the death of the first
world the flood and the beginning of a
new world so Christ is manifesting the
beginning of a new world and then when
we hear that the voice of God above
saying this is my son that is this is
the one that I have engendered this is
the one that I recognize as my own
the one that manif that is manifesting
my identity now into the world that is
of course the idea of what the Son of
God is uh we have a relationship again
between this idea of the Son of God and
the branch that the bird finds in the
world that manifests the the pattern of
a new order which is being born in
reality um you know of course this is
related of course in the Old Testament
it's related somewhat of course to the
voice of God as well that pulls reality
pulls the world pulls creation out of
the waters that separates the waters
that pulls the Earth out of the waters
all of these things are being referred
to of course it's amazing because it's
using images so it can be very simple
with just this one verse and bring out
of of our knowledge all of these other
images that appear in in the Old
Testament okay now so what we're seeing
importantly is to mostly to understand
that what we're seeing is a new
beginning a new Heaven a new connection
between Heaven and Earth or revealing
the connection between Heaven and Earth
and this can be represented in many ways
it could be represented as for example a
new creation a new Kingdom right the
kingdom a new kingdom is also very
important to understand how it connects
which is that a kingdom is similar to a
tree that is a kingdom is the way way
the world lays itself out or in an
orderly way connected to a principality
connected to a King which unites all
this multiplicity together so a tree a
kingdom uh you know and then of course
it can be represented as a new birth as
a new beginning and so once you start to
see these images come together there are
a lot of things in the Bible that will
start to make sense be even though it
sometimes they seem obscure at the
outset and so as we you know what I I
wanted to do is to look at another text
in scripture one which is very popular
especially in kind of American
Christianity and see how we can make
sense of it based
on these images that Christ himself
brings up and this is of course John
3 so we're not going to read all of John
3 but I want to read a part of John 3
starting with verse three where Christ
encounters
Nicodemus so it says now now there was a
Pharisee a man named Nicodemus who was a
member of the Jewish ruling Council he
came to Jesus at night and said Rabbi we
know that you are a teacher who has come
from God no one could perform the signs
you are doing if God were not with him
Jesus replied very truly I tell you no
one can see the kingdom of God unless
they are born again it's like already
it's like if you just look at what is
being said here it is very obscure
despite the fact that some people will
tell us that this is as clear as Crystal
this is very simple right you you can't
see the kingdom unless you're born again
this is this is simple and obvious
um of course Nicodemus asks him how can
someone be born when they are old surely
they cannot enter a second time into
their mother's womb to be
born so Jesus answers very truly I tell
you no one can enter the kingdom of God
unless they are born of water and spirit
flesh gives birth to flesh but spirit
gives birth to
Spirit so he continues and said you
should not be surprised at my saying You
must be born again the wind blows
wherever it pleases you hear its sound
but you cannot tell where it comes from
or where it is going so it is with
everyone born of the spirit and of
course Nicodemus asked how can this be
and so Christ CHR continues and
reproaches him you know and says how
don't you know these things you are a
teacher of Israel how is it that you
don't know these things
so what is it that Christ is talking
about
here of course Christ is referring if
you've read the gospel and you've read
even the gospel of St John if you read
the other gospels you know that he's
referring to the baptism he's referring
to his baptism he's referring to what it
is that happened to him at baptism but
then in the in the same way he's not
just referring to that he's referring to
what it is that baptism means to what it
is that uh the baptism is manifesting in
the world because he says you have to be
born of water and spirit you know that
is what happens in the story of Christ
baptism he descends into the water and
when he comes out of the water then the
spirit comes down upon him and so the
first thing in the image of baptism that
has to happen is what what what happens
at First St John what St John is doing
St John is clearing the way right St
John is the one that baptizes he's
clearing the way he's making a level
he's removing the old structures he's
removing the old things and he's T and
he's making the World level he's making
things straight Paving the the way for
the Lord to come and so that is the
first part of the process you have to
remove the old things and then you have
to be born again
of the spirit you have to be born again
from Heaven that is you have to re re
receive a new identity which comes from
above a new connection which comes from
above and so that is exactly what Christ
is saying that needs to happen now this
has to happen at every level right it's
something that happens at every level of
reality but has to happen if you want to
see the Kingdom of Heaven if you want to
be in the Kingdom of Heaven if you want
to participate in the Kingdom of Heaven
Heaven you have to remove the Old
Kingdom and then you have to be
connected to the New Kingdom which is
the the kingdom of God and so what's
interesting about what happens of course
the way that Christ reveals it is that
it it is happening at every level it has
to happen at every level of reality and
so it of course has to happen internally
and this is usually the way that a lot
of you know uh kind of modern
evangelicals will deal with it they say
this thing has to happen internally that
is that you have to remove the the sins
right you have to confess the sins you
have to kind of remove the old man and
then you have to attach yourself to this
to the the the spirit you have to attach
yourself to that which is above and then
you can live in the kingdom and then the
kingdom will be manifested within you
now that is of course true but it it
also has to happen you know in terms of
your actual participation in the church
and so you have to actually be baptized
that's why Christ is actually baptized
even though Christ didn't need it Christ
is actually baptized to say for this to
happen it's not just about a kind of
mental game or a mental thing or or just
a conviction you have to you also have
to embody it in the world by being
baptized and by receiving the spirit
from above now in Christianity this has
become two sacraments which is the
baptism and chrismation or baptism and
Confirmation that is there's a baptism
from below and then there is this
receiving of the the the anointing right
from above the receiving of that which
comes from above this and this of course
in Orthodoxy is seen as what we call
chrismation which is an anointing on the
person's body which is this image of
Light which comes down which influence
which comes down from above and this has
to to be uh let's say connected with an
actual participation in the body of
Christ in the body of the church and an
actual connection to an authority which
is the fractal representation of this
whole thing that is you can't just be on
your own you also have to have someone
who is manifesting this authority of God
down upon you that that you participate
in and so you can
see that the the simple little verse of
Christ is representing not only the way
that we are transformed and enter into
the kingdom of God not only the way that
we do it internally externally by
actually being baptized and by receiving
the the spirit but then it is really
just once again an image of everything
an image of reality and so you know if
you want and if you want to to make a
meal that you also have to do that that
is that you have to level the
ingredients so that they become a kind
of potential for the the recipe and so
you have to remove the peel you have to
take away the stems you have to take the
bone out or remove the skin or whatever
it is that you're doing to the
ingredients and then you have to align
it attach it to an identity which comes
down from above that is whatever it is
the recipe that you're doing will then
create the kingdom of that recipe within
you know that you're going to make but
that's true of anything it is just an
image of the revelation of how reality
works that is if you want to participate
in any Kingdom in any form of of of
participation whether it's a family a
team anything then this is the process
there has to be a baptism which is that
you have to remove your attachments to
the things that came before you have to
level the remainders of those of you
have to you know clean out the
remainders of your previous attachments
that's a same thing that happens like if
you start a new job right you have to
cut your attachments to your old job you
have to you know take your things out of
that office you know take the take all
the stuff out so that you're not you're
not connected to that ancient identity
anymore and then you have to come out of
that transformation process come out of
the waters and receive the new identity
that you're going to participate in um
so hopefully this is helpful to
understand that like I've say over and
over uh Christianity is revealing to you
the pattern of reality of how it is that
complexity Works how it is that any type
of unity and multiplicity cohere but
that also means that you you know it is
calling you to actually participate in
that in a real way which is it's not
just showing you the pattern of reality
abstractly but calling you to be
baptized to be chrismated and to enter
into the kingdom in a very explicit
practical way as well and so so I wish
you all a blessed theophany I hope that
uh that you that this was helpful to you
and uh thanks for your support everyone
I really appreciate it in these strange
times and I will talk to you very soon
bye-bye